Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I am Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab, the podcast. And,
um, here's what I want to do today. You know,
we just did the hour long show up at the Galapagos. Yeah.
And in the middle of that show,
we hit on this idea that there are so many of us on the planet now doing so many
different things which affect the air and the water that the creatures on the
planet, um,
can no longer really be uninfluenced by our presence.
They can't be truly wild. And that made me
wonder, well,
if you want to give the other creatures on earth a little more room to be wild
and independent, and what do we have to give up? In fact,
how much are we willing to give up to make that happen?
Uh, I don't know that these are, these are tough questions.
Um, I mean, you know, I'm not good at the answer part. Right? You read them.
This is John Malala. Uh, I'm John McClellan.
I wrote a book called wild ones and I'm a writer with the New York Times
magazine and being a writer, he told me a story. Oh,
this is a story which shed some light on this question,
but I think you'd have to say it's a difficult light.
So, um,
there was a family of whooping cranes that had been part of it.
The story revolves around a project to create a wild flock of whooping cranes.
One of the most spectacular birds in the world, five foot tall is pitch white,
dealing with black wingtips gonna seven foot wingspan. Beautiful Flyer.
This is Joe Duff. I'm the CO founder of Operation Migration,
the current CEO.
Now we've done a story on operation migration before and Radiolab.
But here's the, here's the gist. At one point,
the whooping crane population in North America was down to like 15 birds,
just one flock.
So Joe and a bunch of other folks decided to to see if they could start a new
flock of cranes.
So they raised some cranes in Wisconsin and then they teach them a new migration
route to Florida by leading them there in an ultra light airplane. Yeah.
Joe, in addition to being founder and CEO is also the lead pilot.
And how long have you been, you've been doing this for awhile, right, man?
I started flying with birds in 93, 20 years.
And the key to this whole project, Joe says, is to eliminate all things human.
And these are wild creatures. You know,
when we do this whole thing in full costume, so the birds don't hear voices.
They don't, uh,
they don't see buildings or any other human paraphernalia in order in order to
maintain their wildness.
Jill even wears an all white cream like a costume when he's up there in the
ultra light
leading the birds down to Florida. And when they get to Florida,
and cranes are supposed to, you know, they're brought to this, um,
[inaudible] national wildlife refuge.
It's a coastal wetland. It's all a salt marsh in the Tampa area.
And the birds are put into a, it's called a release pad.
It is a 12 foot high fences protected by electric wire,
but the whole complex is not top netted. And so, um,
after a while the birds realized they can fly out,
then they go seek out their own territory. It's
called a gentle release into the wild or they're not so well.
And here's where the problem starts.
It's the winter of 2007 and we've got a particular bunch of cranes
and his family, they were called the first family cause they were the first, um,
cranes in the population to have a, have a chick that they led south,
the first wild hatch migratory whooping crane in the u s since the last nest was
reported in 1878. And these cranes had wound up in, in this little subdivision,
a a wetland complex that was surrounded by houses.
It was perfect crane habitat. It was,
it was basically a marsh just so happened that it was in this,
this woman's backyard. And so the, the birds,
which had been the product of this, you know,
very intensive effort and tons of money,
here's a thousands of dollars an hour,
um, to be wild whooping cranes. We're now just in her backyard. And there was,
there was free food there. She had all these bird feeders,
this whole array of different bird feeders, upright and yard.
And that's not good sign. Why? Why is this a problem? Well,
the problem is we're worried that the birds are going to become acclimated to
people to be really safe. Joe says these birds should be afraid of people.
Six of them have been shot by vandals. Six birds have been shot.
Six whooping grains had been shot in this project by vandals. Yeah.
So what do you do? We asked the people to stop feeding.
Would you have like a reverse phone directory or do you have a ups?
Don't we track? The birds are all tracked. And so they knew exactly where they,
where they were and they were able to figure out that the cranes were in the
backyard of someone named music.
Gibbs. Claris Clarice. Yes. Clarice Gibbs. And,
uh, you know, they knocked on our door and explained, you know,
the whole ins and outs of the project and would you please take your bird
feeders down? And uh, she said, she said no,
no. Yeah. Why would she say no?
Well,
John talked to the people who went to see her and know they didn't say crazy,
but you got the sense that there was this, you know, crazy old bird lady.
You lived in this house who'd move, would not take her feeders down.
They told John that she, they thought he was acting kind of erratic and uh,
and things just kept getting worse and worse.
And they had actually gone in and put a plastic fence around one of her feeders
at one point. What was she, they had thought she had given permission,
but she had no memory of that. So it got, it got bitter pretty fast.
And so John decided, I'm going to go talk to this woman. Yeah. So I,
I was sort of girding myself for a, you know,
crazy old bird lady who lived in this house,
but I w but I went to go see her and, uh, you know, is it was a,
how do I even talk about it? And it was a really emotional day for me. Um,
we sat her at her dining room table and she was having a lot of trouble
remembering the exact chronology of what had happened when, um, she, uh,
you know, she said, excuse me,
I'm just hard for me to kind of piece things together around that,
around that time. And, uh, and basically this story emerged
that time of, oh gosh,
when we heard that story, we decided we needed to talk to [inaudible] ourselves.
So we called her up out of kind of the blue and asked her if we could record the
conversation record. We would love to do it.
Well, no, it wouldn't bother me at all. I wouldn't mind.
Okay. So you are about to Clarice. Tell us her. Uh, I got,
I gotta say it's a sort of surprising version of this tale in just a second.
My name is Zachary ESMO from Sarasota, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the national science foundation by the Alfred p
Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
You vote with your dollars when you shop. Well,
what if you could do the same when you invest with swell,
invest in high growth companies without checking your values at the door.
It's a market opportunity linked to global progress in clean water when you
will, bill energy medical breakthroughs could get a $50 bonus when you open your
account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab.
We're back and we, we've just called up Clarice Gibbs.
It wouldn't bother me at all. I wouldn't mind.
Okay, so you were about to say that you're, first of all the description, you,
how many bird feeders did you have in the backyard would you say? Roughly?
Um, at that time, uh,
I think I had two or three in an oak tree that's here in our backyard.
And where we live is, um, it's just, you know,
it's a peaceful area in bird flight, things like that.
They don't like to be allowed around a lot of congestion and stuff. And, uh,
we enjoy them. Well, I say we hum. When my husband was alive, we, you know,
we both enjoyed the birds and see them.
This is where the story flipped for me because when those conservationists were
knocking at Clarissa's door, her husband of more than 15
d years,
he had Alzheimer's and they were sort of hunkered down at their house waiting
for his Vern, his life to end. Okay.
Yeah. This was, this was before, uh, you know,
the Alzheimer's cooking really bad.
And what they were doing was spending a lot of time on their back porch looking
at the bird.
And we wouldn't come out here and sit with our tea or lemonade. Um,
he would, uh, he would just kind of watch
[inaudible]
our back porch, of course faces the lake. We have a beautiful yard,
we have oak trees. And as I'm sitting here talking to you,
there's all kinds of birds around right now feeding. Um,
we even have sandhill cranes that have two babies with them.
So Clarice and her husband would be there on the porch.
And if you have had this disease in your family,
you know how painful it is because here's her husband and he is just
disappearing a little bit and little bit more.
And then he's mostly not there. But when a bird or a bunch of birds come by,
the bird feeders from wherever he was,
he's back.
As soon as he would spot something, he'd say, Babe, there is, there it is.
There's the hummingbird.
And when the whooping crane showed up big and white and wild,
that would really get his attention cause they are such big, beautiful birds.
You know, I could see the, Oh gosh,
like I happiness in his eyes and he would smile.
Oh to me it was like, you know, he,
he came back to me for a little bit when, when he would see things like this,
it would just, it would make him so happy and it would make me happy too,
to see how it affected him.
I'm sorry, I just, I,
I get, uh, kind of choked up when I talk about him.
We were married for 56 years when that disease took him and it was hard.
ARD
from her point of view,
it was like a miracle to see a bird like that and the way that her husband
responded to them and just the, you know, the way they,
that they took his breath away, um, when really, you know,
he wasn't responding to, uh, to a lot else in the world.
It's a blessing, you know, when, when they seem to recognize things and,
and then you lose them again, you know? Yeah.
So that's why when the crane people showed up at her door and said,
please take the boot feeder down. She said, no,
you know, I left that house. Uh, just, you know, I just couldn't figure out, um,
how to make sense of it all once I, once I had left.
Have the people who visited her having read your account,
have they changed their minds at all about her or what they do because it's a
toughie. This, this session.
Yeah. I'm sure they would still believe that the birds shouldn't have been fed.
But I don't know if they would be any more sympathetic to, or no
desire to see her husband. And these birds, oddly enough, are the trigger.
So I told Joe Clarissa's story. So now what do you say?
Well, you know,
my father died of Alzheimer's so I can respect to exactly what she's going
through and how difficult it is. However,
the cost of that is the demise of a bird that,
that either people have spent a huge amount of time in 24 hours a day,
seven days a week for that entire bird's life until it was a year old putting in
the wild to help save a species. But if you put yourself in her shoes,
she says, she, by the way, was very careful.
I, I was very,
very emphatic that we didn't mess with the birds because I knew they didn't want
them being confronted with, with people, you know, they,
because they are a wild thing. And, and uh, it's,
it, to me, it, it, I don't know. I,
we've always loved nature and we've just always loved nature and,
and the wildlife.
So she stayed where, where she felt you'd want her to stay.
But it's a hard one to ask that she give up a glimpse at her husband for the
sake of the birds. I suppose
I'm a little more pragmatic than that unfortunately. Hmm. You would want,
you would have him make an exception for her. Well,
at the very least I would have him,
cause I understand that she's in a unique place that he's, no,
I don't mean it's unique. Well, I, maybe she is in her particulars,
but that is precisely the problem he has to deal with it.
Are People like her. She means well, we all mean, well,
it's not a case of like people with guns shooting these birds.
I mean that does happen, but I don't think that's the big problem. No,
these are two people who both love the bird but can't agree on something. Right.
And he saying in order to love the bird, you have to negate, you have to just,
you'd have to disappear. And we can't, as human beings,
we don't seem to be able to do that.
We all have our own personal requirements and we put those over and above
anything else, including wildlife. And that's why wildlife is,
is in such peril.
[inaudible]
he's asking her to say goodbye to her husband for the sake of a bird species.
I knew I ate. I just worry that if everybody in the world is like her,
then those birds don't have a chance.
[inaudible]
I would love it if these birds could just exist on their own somewhere and
[inaudible] in deep water marshes where they don't ever encounter people.
But that's never going to happen. It's just not going to happen.
[inaudible]
and that's the struggle. It's never gonna go away. You know? No matter what,
no matter what happens with any of these species conservation projects,
we're not going to strike some balance where we never have to think about the
power that we're exerting in the world. This give and take it. That's,
that's what it is. That's the end game. It's, it's that forever.
[inaudible] uh,
special thanks to Simon Adler who, uh, who,
whom ferried us through this whole project and also to John McClellan book.
The wild ones is, uh, the source of the story.
I am Robert Krulwich, Janet. Boom. Ron, we'll be back next time.